[Música]
la primera reunión presencial que tienen
los cuatro presidentes de los países que
están en mercosur deja una gran pregunta
Uruguay está cada vez más distante del
bloque sudamericano que comparte con
Brasil Argentina y Paraguay el gobierno
uruguayo publicó su propia declaración y
el mandatario Luis lacalle Pou no firmó
el documento final que publicaron Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva Alberto Fernández
y Mario abdo Benítez El punto de
discordia es el tratado de libre
comercio que quiere tener con China y
otro gran tema que se discutió fue el
acuerdo entre mercosur y la Unión
Europea al que estos latinoamericanos
miran con cierto recelo por las
restricciones ambientales que tienen los
europeos frente a las importaciones de
alimentos habrá un pacto comercial y qué
pasará con Uruguay hoy en el debate nos
acompaña desde Montevideo Nicolás pose
docente e investigador en economía
política internacional en la universidad
de la república Y desde buenos nos
acompaña Delia flores especialista en
mercosur y empresaria en servicio al
comercio exterior aduana y Transporte
internacional de cargas a ellos dos
Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en Flash
veinticuatro y a quienes nos ven y nos
escuchan les recuerdo que pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios en las redes
sociales con el hashtag el debate f24
También estamos en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram como arroba Franz 24 raya al
piso es y yo estoy como arroba María
claguire también quiero darle un saludo
especial a quienes nos escuchan a través
de nuestros podcast disponibles en Apple
podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar Entonces primero que
todo dándole la bienvenida a Nicolás por
acompañarnos Nicolás Bienvenido al
debate de France 24 y la pregunta
inicial es Cómo entender el comunicado o
la declaración final que publicó de
manera unilateral Uruguay
bueno Primero que nada Muchas gracias
por la invitación es un gusto para mí
estar aquí con ustedes en segundo lugar
agregar que esta no es la primera
ocasión en la que Uruguay este no accede
a firmar el el comunicado final de este
tras una Cumbre presidencial de de
mercosur de hecho ya tenemos
antecedentes en el marco de estos
últimos años ha sido una política
llevada adelante por el gobierno
uruguayo encabezado por el presidente de
la calle Pou en la medida que el resto
de Los Socios de mercosur en particular
los más grandes pero también acompañado
por Paraguay no han aceptado la
propuesta o la demanda de Uruguay de
flexibilizar el bloque por
flexibilización entiendo una cosa bien
concreta que es la posibilidad de que
los miembros de mercosur firmen por su
cuenta bilateralmente acuerdos de
comercio preferencial con terceros
Uruguay está en particular interesado en
procurar un acuerdo de este tipo con
china inició un estudio de factibilidad
Conjunto con con miras hacia ese
objetivo pero lo cierto Es que se ha
enfrentado a la restricción de que los
de mercosur han decidido negociar
preferencias arancelarias con terceros
de forma conjunta dada la unión aduanera
Aunque imperfecta que mantienen en vigor
el bloque regional en ese marco Uruguay
al enfrentar la negativa de sus miembros
a flexibilizar esta disposición es que
bueno opta por este camino de no firmar
la declaración común y por el contrario
publicar un comunicador separado Delia
Bienvenida al debate de France 24
Nicolás ya nos explicaba y nos daba
labrebocas sobre la palabra clave o una
de las claves en estas declaraciones y
es la flexibilidad que pide Uruguay a
mercosur mercosur por el contrario no
publica esta palabra en su comunicado A
qué se debe esto especialmente teniendo
en cuenta que al igual que Uruguay
Brasil también tiene como su mayor
Aliado comercial a China
Hola Qué tal Buenas tardes y bueno
Muchas gracias también por estar por
permitirme estar aquí
yo creo que el mercosur está estancado
ya de hace más de diez años y esta
flexibilidad que pide Uruguay en la
práctica es la que todos deberíamos
pedir porque ha quedado como bien dice
Ignacio en solamente en una Unión y
aduanera imperfecta y no ha avanzado más
lógicamente china no aceptó hacer hacer
un acuerdo o en forma bilateral con
Uruguay porque esto no está contemplado
en en el acuerdo del mercosur que obliga
a que se realicen acuerdos cuando todo
el bloque está este cuando todo el
bloque lo acepta
lógicamente la palabra flexibilizar no
no no no
aparece en este comunicado porque
evidentemente
el resto del grupo no no está apoyando
todavía esta este esta flexibilización
de hacer acuerdos bilaterales este de
los países miembros ustedes tienen un
punto en común y es decir mercosur está
estancado Le quiero preguntar sobre un
punto y es que usted habla de una Unión
aduanera imperfecta y de hecho las
aduanas también y los aranceles también
fueron uno de los puntos que Uruguay
recalcó En su declaración única y que no
está en el comunicado de mercosur
Uruguay por ejemplo dice que no hay
arancel externo común dentro de los
cuatro países de mercosur y también se
queja de que haya restricciones no
arancelarias es decir cuando un país
puede tomar una decisión unilateral para
impedir que algún producto de los otros
tres países ingrese a su propio
territorio cómo es posible que mercosur
se haya creado con la intención de ser
un mercado único casi un libre comercio
dentro de los cuatro países o los países
miembros de mercosur y no exista ni un
arancel común y además haya
restricciones unilaterales
exactamente Es lo que bien decís el
mercosur fue creado con la finalidad de
llegar a ser un mercado común pero no
llegó llegó a su ante último escalón
peldaño que es el del mercado el de la
unión aduanera imperfecta porque no
llegó a finalizar el
escalón de la unión aduanera y falta
voluntad política claramente falta
voluntad política falta decisión de los
porque cuando llegan a un determinado
punto que es por ejemplo cómo repartimos
los derechos de los aranceles de este de
extra zona cuando entran a determinados
puertos Cómo repartimos por ejemplo con
Paraguay que Paraguay no tiene Puerto es
un país mediterráneo cómo repartimos
esos aranceles que quizás recibe Brasil
De esta zona en el puerto de Santos por
darte un ejemplo se quedó trabado en eso
decir falta voluntad política faltan
tomar esas decisiones de fondo que
afectan totalmente claramente a la parte
monetaria como también los aranceles De
esta zona y como Bueno una serie de
cosas y medidas para arancelarias de
todo tipo
fundamentalmente se ven claramente a lo
largo de Mi historia en el comercio
exterior entre Argentina y Brasil he
visto
periodos de muchas medidas para
arancelarias de un lado y del otro
llámese por ejemplo disfrazadas bajo
certificados sanitarios o alguna plaga
casi inventada que que hace que se
rechacen productos en determinada altura
de del comercio o
licencias de importación que son casi
cepos en la Argentina que produce gente
muchísimos reclamos por parte de la
industria brasilera y así En definitiva
hermanos pero no tanto y yo veo no que
se habló mucho de integración de
proyectos en común pero no se habló de
lo más importante y la cuestión más de
fondo decir cómo vamos a avanzar con el
mercosur cómo vamos a dar ese paso más
que está faltando para llegar a ser una
unión aduanera para mejorar los aspectos
migratorios para unificar determinadas
cosas que aún no están unificadas y para
llegar finalmente a ese mercado común
este que fue la visión fundacional de
aquellos presidentes y teniendo esto en
cuenta Nicolás entonces usted qué cree
que pueda pasar con mercosur coinciden
en que está congelado pero se puede
hablar de que en algunos años pueda
dejar de existir dadas estas divisiones
internas y estas diferencias o no y que
por el contrario incluso la idea de
incluir a Bolivia podría hablar de que
mercosur sigue y seguirá vivo
yo creo que una característica que que
ha marcado a mercosur en su historia de
32 años es por un lado la resiliencia es
decir el bloque a pesar de las múltiples
crisis políticas y económicas que han
atravesado sus miembros a pesar de la
multiplicidad de dificultades para
comerciar para arribar acuerdos comunes
muchas veces para implementar los
acuerdos comunes a los que se arriban lo
cierto es que el bloque sigue allí
permanece ya sobrevivido a distintas
coyunturas que lo pusieron bajo tensión
tal vez la más reciente la constatamos
en el marco de de dos gobiernos en la
Argentina y Brasil de signo político muy
distinto al gobierno de Jair bolsonaro y
el gobierno de Alberto Fernández en
donde los presidentes prácticamente no
tenían contacto a nivel personal en
donde había una una fuerte animosidad
entre ambos gobiernos y así todo lo que
logra sobrevivir logra seguir adelante
lo que nos muestra que por un lado las
partes los países que lo integran
valoran la existencia de mercosur porque
de lo contrario se hubieran retirado o
hubieran desarmado este el mecanismo
dicho esto a pesar de la resiliencia del
bloque Lo cierto es que también se
constatan este persistentemente
dificultades para avanzar para resolver
distintas cuestiones que están
pendientes en la agenda de mercosur por
un lado asegurar una efectiva concreción
del área de libre comercio es decir
remover las barreras no arancelarias al
comercio intra-regional a las que hacía
referencia Delia perfeccionar los
instrumentos de relacionamiento externo
con el resto del mundo ya sea
consolidando una arancel externo como
uno o buscando alguna otra alternativa
que permita por lo menos ordenar una
gran dispersión que existe hoy a nivel
del del arancel exno común sobre todo a
partir de de estas dinámicas
negociadoras entre Argentina y Brasil
entre 2019-2020 cuando Brasil procuró
reducir el arancel externo común
argentina se oponía a esa medida y bueno
llegaron a un acuerdo de compromiso en
el cual se aplicó una rebaja algunos
bienes no a otros y la cual Brasil la ha
implementado en mayor medida que este el
el país este argentino por lo que es
cierto que hay una necesidad de
reordenar un montón de instrumentos un
montón de herramientas pero así todo
también vemos la la continuidad del
bloque e incluso como tú bien
mencionabas la búsqueda de otros países
de acceder es el caso de Bolivia que
espera hasta el día de hoy por la
decisión del Congreso brasileño tenemos
la voluntad de los cuatro ejecutivos que
integran este como miembros plenos
actualmente mercosur tenemos este
también la la voluntad de los
parlamentos de Uruguay de Paraguay de
Argentina pero este el ingreso como
miembro pleno de Bolivia al mercosur
permanece estancado en el congreso
brasileño así que bueno para resumir yo
diría por un lado resiliencia por un
lado este continuidad en este esquema
que que ya lleva tres décadas y que
Bueno este ya eso en en sí mismo tiene
un valor dadas las las dificultades para
la integración económica en América
Latina por otro lado un conjunto de desa
que efectivamente hay que abordar de
cara al futuro Aunque la pausa de que
Bolivia haga parte uno de mercosur en
este momento está en el campo de juego
de Brasil también dice mucho lo que pasó
con el comunicado de Uruguay porque el
gobierno uruguayo simplemente destacó
con esta palabra destacamos la reunión
de adhesión que se hizo con Bolivia en
miras de de vincularlo al bloque
mientras que en el comunicado conjunto
fueron mucho más positivos y dijeron que
expresaban su voluntad en avanzar en esa
adhesión hay una oposición de Uruguay a
que Bolivia pertenezca a mercosur sobre
todo por las diferencias políticas entre
el gobierno de Luis lacalle Pou y el
gobierno de Luis Arce
Bueno lo que hemos conocido por por los
reportes este paralelos que han surgido
en torno a la Cumbre es que Uruguay en
realidad no accedió o o puso un Matiz
con respecto a esta cuestión en el
entendido de que ya todos los ejecutivos
han dado el visto bueno para que Bolivia
acceda y que solamente falta el paso
este de de ratificación en el congreso
brasileño Entonces el gobierno uruguayo
argumenta que no era necesario una
formulación del estilo como tal como se
plasma en el comunicado de los tres
países que firmaron un comunicado un
comunicado conjunto sino que simplemente
lo que va Lo que lo que queda pendiente
es esperar por la ratificación del
Congreso de Brasil yo creo que en
realidad lo que refleja esto es un en
descontento una insatisfacción más
general de Uruguay con el funcionamiento
del bloque en particular en la cuestión
que hablábamos de las relaciones con el
resto del mundo y con algunas cuestiones
del funcionamiento intra zona que se
derivan en estas cuestiones por ejemplo
en esta cuestión de marcar un Matiz en
un tema que no es entrar en la agenda
este de Uruguay u otro Matiz que no
surgió comunicado de Uruguay pero que sí
lo pudimos observar en las alocuciones
de los presidentes cuando el presidente
de la calle Pou plantea que en el marco
de la Cumbre celac mercosur Espera que
el presidente ucraniano Celeste tenga la
posibilidad de de abordar a la reunión y
presentar la situación de Ucrania en el
contexto de de la guerra de la invasión
rusa sabemos que el resto de los países
de la región han mantenido una posición
en la que si bien condenan esta esta
invasión han procurado mantenerse algo
más neutrales en torno a este conflicto
y por lo tanto no han aceptado la este
solicitud de la Unión Europea de que en
la Cumbre celac Unión Europea que tendrá
lugar en las próximas semanas exista
esta intervención de Ucrania qué es lo
que muestra Esto bueno muestran un
descontento más general con la de
Uruguay con la situación del bloque que
se expresa a través de distintos canales
pero que el centro de la cuestión está
en las relaciones de mercosur con el
resto del mundo y en la posibilidad de
cada uno de los miembros o no de
vincularse por su cuenta con otros
países y regiones y otro de los
descontentos es sobre Venezuela que
también lo vamos a abordar más adelante
pero antes le quiero preguntar a Delia
si tiene para usted algún sentido que un
mecanismo como mercosur que todavía no
termina de funcionar adecuadamente se le
sume otro jugador como a Bolivia
yo creo que sí que que este creo que
tiene sentido porque es más La pregunta
sería por qué no Bolivia porque somos
países vecinos limítrofes unos con otros
entonces me parece que estaría faltando
Bolivia en el mercosur y claramente en
la voluntad del presidente Lula da Silva
entre los objetivos que se propuso en
Durante este semestre su mandato está el
de Finalmente a adherir con conseguir
concluir la adhesión de Bolivia al
bloque también habla de este pensando en
lo que decía Nicolás recién hay dos ya
objetivos que Lula se plantea que ella
libre comercio para dos productos si
bien Son productos que claramente
benefician a Brasil como la industria
autopartista la de los sector automotor
y la caña de azúcar pero ya se está
hablando de libre comercio entonces
Yo creo que el mercosur este bloque
resiliente que ya tiene más de 30 años
va a permanecer no no le veo que que
arriesgue su vida lo que sí digo es que
hay decisiones de fondo que son
profundas que necesitan
consensos que necesitan inclusive
negociaciones y ceder de cada cada uno
Un poco
yo creo que el mercosur sigue viviendo y
y este no no no no no se termina no se
termina cree usted entonces Delia quiero
regresar con Nicolás muy brevemente para
que comentemos las diferencias de nuevo
del presidente uruguayo Luis lacalle Pou
frente a Venezuela unas diferencias que
ya venían desde antes las veíamos en la
Cumbre que hizo Brasil para la
integración regional y a la que fue el
presidente Nicolás maduro y que también
Tuvo una diferencia entre la calle Pou y
Gabriel boric que se opusieron a las
palabras de Lula que un poco matizaba la
situación en Venezuela en esta Cumbre
precisamente de mercosur que se realizó
en Puerto iguazú Argentina de nuevo
vuelve a la mesa la diferencia de
Venezuela sin embargo Venezuela no es un
país miembro de mercosur usted cree que
puede generar algunas consecuencias en
las divisiones dentro del grupo bueno
Venezuela es un miembro del del mercosur
que está suspendido desde hace algunos
años por la aplicación de la cláusula
democrática y en ese marco Este ahí a
diferencia de otros asuntos las
posiciones de Uruguay y de paraguayna
han coincidido en señalar que bueno que
no se han generado la las condiciones de
un retorno a un régimen político
democrático como para rehabilitar el
ingreso de Venezuela es decir este estos
gobiernos demandan que para que
Venezuela se reincorpore como miembro
pleno mercosur bueno Primero se constata
en efectivamente avances en términos de
una mayor democratización de su régimen
político de todos modos yo creo que con
la amplia agenda de de temas que tiene
pendiente mercosur y con los desafíos
que bien planteaba Delia y con la
necesidad de que cada una de las
decisiones mercosur este arriba un
consenso esa es un aspecto muy
importante que vale la pena señalar
porque muchas veces la la falta de la de
toma de decisiones o o la lentitud para
arribar a decisiones comunes obedece al
hecho de que mercosur para funcionar
para tomar nuevas decisiones requiere de
la anuencia de todas las partes requiere
del consenso de todos sus miembros Bueno
creo que ni Brasil ni Argentina este van
a invertir un fuerte capital político en
esta cuestión sino que bueno hay otros
temas que están arriba de la mesa y que
van a estar marcando la agenda del
segundo semestre en particular este
estimo que Durante este segundo semestre
la cuestión de la negociación con la
Unión Europea intentando bueno concretar
este acuerdo que lleva también este algo
así como veinte años o algo más de 20
años de de proceso negociador bueno
efectivamente este se se concrete O al
menos que este las partes logren acercar
sus posiciones para retomar un acuerdo
que de hecho ya se se había acordado en
principio en junio de 2019 pero que
luego por las objeciones europe a este
la ausencia de instrumentos ambientales
este más de mayor vinculación este que
puedan este imponer sanciones este
sujetas al no cumplimiento de los
compromisos ambientales adoptados por
las partes hicieron que este acuerdo se
frenará en Europa y que luego Bueno este
dado el nuevo contexto geopolítico
global y el cambio de signo político en
Brasil la Unión Europea haya retomado
esta negociación haya este trasladado a
los miembros de mercosur una nueva
propuesta con un instrumento ambiental
adicional y que los miembros del
mercosur si bien no aceptan esta
formulación original europea bueno se
han comprometido a realizar una
contrapropuesta para negociar durante el
segundo semestre de este año
coincidiendo además con las presidencias
pro tempore de Brasil en mercosur y de
España en la Unión Europea que
tradicionalmente ha sido un país muy
afina este instrumento entonces creo que
para el segundo semestre la agenda va a
estar marcada por esta negociación
externa y por algunos asuntos de la
agenda intrarregional como bien
planteaba él ya la cuestión de los
sectores que todavía permanecen
excluidos de la zona de libre comercio
este de mercosur Automotriz este sector
azucarero y por la remoción de Barreras
no arancelarias o la búsqueda de
mecanismos que permitan superar
restricciones estructurales Como por
ejemplo las que las que atraviesa
Argentina con sus este dificultades
financieras y en ese contexto la
búsqueda de comerciar monedas locales o
generar mecanismos de compensación de
pagos que permitan este re impulsar el
comercio interregional que parece ser
uno de los objetivos de Brasil y en ese
caso si compartido por el resto de los
miembros del bloque y ya vamos a
analizar también el punto con la Unión
Europea y el acuerdo tan esperado y que
en dos décadas no se ha podido concretar
Delia sin embargo Quiero preguntarle
Nicolás afirma que ni Brasil ni
Argentina van a poner tanto esfuerzo
político para vincular de nuevo a
Venezuela a mercosur usted considera que
la posición de Lula sí va a ser apoyar a
Venezuela y a su reingreso a los
diferentes mecanismos que existan en la
región incluido mercosur o no
yo creo que va a apoyar pero hasta
cierto punto
Lamentablemente el mercosur está
dividido inclusive este en partes
iguales de casi diría por cuestiones
ideológicas claramente se nota ahí la
ideología porque Uruguay y Paraguay
opinan de un modo y Argentina y Brasil
de otro pero creo que realmente Lula el
presidente Lula no va a gastar tanto
este capital político en Venezuela
Brasil tiene tiene políticas claras
tiene objetivos claros y y realmente
conociendo como Cómo funcionan yo creo
que este el apoyo va a ser este
como diría
más sutil más sutil Por decirlo así
más diplomático no se va no se va a
jugar la vida ni la ni el liderazgo por
una cuestión este ideológica claro Ahora
sí viremos hacia el exterior y hay dos
jugadores claves sobre la mesa para
mercosur uno es la Unión Europea con el
que están intentando lograr un acuerdo
comercial desde hace 20 años como bien
lo decía Nicolás y por el otro lado está
China que Uruguay de manera unilateral
ha intentado hacer un tratado de libre
comercio con los chinos Pero hay un
elemento Aquí súper importante y es que
china es el mayor socio comercial es con
el que más exportaciones tienen tanto
Brasil como Uruguay Uruguay exporta un
28% de sus productos a China y Brasil lo
hace con el 26% de sus productos y luego
de esto ya los socios comerciales van
variando para Uruguay por ejemplo es la
Unión Europea el segundo para Brasil es
Estados Unidos mientras que las
condiciones de Argentina y Paraguay son
un poco diferentes porque sus mayores
socios comerciales son precisamente los
miembros de mercosur Entonces en este
sentido Brasil y Uruguay tendrían
razones para tener mayor interés en que
se avance en un acuerdo con la Unión
Europea o con china le pregunto Delia
precisamente por la Unión Europea porque
aquí el punto de discusión es el llamado
pacto verde que en 2019 recordemos
mercosur firma un acuerdo con la Unión
Europea pero también en ese año en 2019
en la Unión Europea los 27 de países del
bloque firman el pacto verde que es con
el que se comprometen a lograr la
neutralidad de carbono al 2050 y hacen
siete Pilares de manera interna pero que
también afectan a sus socios comerciales
y en América Latina hay la la
preocupación sobre tres de ellos y es la
deforestación los y los empaques que
sean biodegradables y reciclables y
demás sobre todo un dato porque le
quiero preguntar de ella sobre si
realmente los los cuatro países de
mercosur tendrían o no una desventaja Y
es que por ejemplo la Unión Europea
quiere sancionar una lista de pesticidas
y agroquímicos que son los que usa
precisamente las plantaciones de soya y
un tercio del territorio latinoamericano
está sembrado en soya y los exportadores
por excelencia de soya en mercosur son
sin duda alguna Brasil Argentina y
Uruguay hay una balanza desequilibrada
en este sentido y es por eso la
reticencia de mercosur de firmar el
acuerdo con la Unión Europea
Yo creo que el mercosur tiene interés es
decir tiene interés en firmar el acuerdo
de del mercosur con la Unión Europea
el tema de los pesticidas y del pacto
verde se trata lo que están tratando de
demostrar nuestros presidentes Es que la
balanza está muy inclinada hacia un lado
quizás Brasil con esta cuidado del medio
ambiente con excesivo cuidado del medio
ambiente Por así decirlo de la Unión
Europea
Brasil sea el más afectado porque no
solamente estamos hablando de pesticidas
sino también la deforestación del
Amazonas este el el interés de Francia
porque creo que el que más se opone a
esto es Francia hay también hay que ver
que desmembrar un poco Cuáles son los
países que
se oponen al pacto y cuáles son los
países que van a favor del pacto
entonces hay muchas cuestiones este
económicas
proteccionismo mucho proteccionismo por
parte de la Unión Europea que también
este el mercosur reclama es como que la
balanza el proteccionismo es desigual Es
decir cuestiona nuestro nuestras cosas
pero no miran que ellos están
exageradamente protegiendo otras cosas
entonces
puede ser cuestiones de de pesticidas
pero también este hay muchas cuestiones
de de proteccionismo que la Unión
Europea no quiere
soltar que no quiere que quiere seguir
cuidando porque claramente desde su
interés económico Nicolás antes de
preguntarle por esa proteccionismo Y si
usted está de acuerdo no le quiero hacer
una pregunta y es no es un poco
hipócrita por parte de los países de
mercosur decir Nosotros somos líderes
ambientales Brasil tomar el liderazgo
ambiental contra la deforestación pero a
la hora de sentarse con la Unión Europea
decir No pero no quiero que nos pongan
tantas restricciones para que los
productos por ejemplo la carne no venga
de Campos que han sido deforestados
bueno a ver lo que sucede es que este en
20 años de de negociación en el arribo a
a un acuerdo que
compensara un poco las las ganancias y
las pérdidas de de cada una de las
partes en en estas tratativas tan
complejas fue al el arribo a un
equilibrio muy delicado un equilibrio
que quede de un hilo por por ponerlo de
modo bien ilustrativo por algo la
negociación fue fue tan arduo durante
tantos años y por algo durante tantos
años las partes no lograron ponerse de
acuerdo cuando en junio de 2019 los dos
bloques cierran un acuerdo en principio
Bueno finalmente habían alcanzado ese
compromiso que balanceaba un poco
ganancias y pérdidas para ambas regiones
en el marco de un acuerdo comercial Lo
que sucede es que
estas nuevas exigencias que aparecen
desde la Unión Europea para por otro
lado tratar de de aminorar las
resistencias internas que este acuerdo
genera en Europa en algunos países como
Francia como bien decía Delia y en otros
países otros este incluso parlamentos
nacionales que también se han
manifestado en contra del acuerdo Lo que
sucede es que esto cambie un poco Esas
reglas de juego que se habían acordado
en 2019 cambio un poco el balance de
costos y beneficios esperados por lo que
allí surgen contrapropuestas desde
países como Argentina desde países como
Brasil de decir Bueno sí se va a
plantear la necesidad de rediscutir una
adenda ambiental Por qué no discutir el
capítulo de compras gubernamentales como
ha planteado Brasil para reservar sus
mayores espacio para sus políticas de
desarrollo doméstico Por qué no re
discutir como ha planteado el gobierno
Argentina el gobierno de Argentina las
implicaciones como tú bien decías del
pacto verde para las este para las
ventas de mercosur Unión Europea que
pueden ir incluso independientemente
este a la vida de este acuerdo porque
las exportaciones de de soja del
mercosur hacia Unión Europea no están
grabadas por aranceles es decir que
incluso la ausencia de un acuerdo estas
exportaciones ya están yendo a Europa
libre de impuestos Lo que sucede es que
estas nuevas restricciones que por este
por motivos ambientales pueden
introducir barreras no arancelarias lo
que hacen es amenazar este balance de
costos y beneficios para ambas partes
que como decía el la negociación de 2019
es el resultado de un equilibrio este
muy muy delicado este muy este se quiere
fácilmente de romper y un poco lo que
está sobre la mesa es eso es el cambio
de las reglas del juego y bueno la
necesidad de buscar un nuevo equilibrio
que consiga que ambas regiones puedan
finalmente concretizar este esperado
acuerdo Delia con este proteccionismo
del que usted nos hablaba y el delicado
balance que plantea Nicolás Qué tan
lejos o qué tan cerca está que mercosur
finalmente firme y pacte un acuerdo con
la Unión Europea
yo creo que estamos cerca creo que
estamos cerca hay hay voluntad de de
varios países de la Unión Europea hay
voluntad también del mercosur
independientemente de estas este de este
complicado equilibrio que tenemos que
buscar no el proteccionismo el
proteccionismo también en las compras
nacionales que decía Nicolás es verdad
Este nosotros nuestros países prefieren
este que las compras públicas darle
prioridad a las empresas nacionales pero
todos son cosas que se pueden ir
conversando Lo importante es que se vaya
avanzando que se reuniones ir
destrabando cosas por cosas pero me
parece que que Hay posibilidad de decir
de que este acuerdo avance y que
finalmente se concrete a propósito de
las reuniones que usted menciona hay un
punto y es Cómo lograr que finalmente se
concrete este acuerdo teniendo aún las
diferencias dentro de mercosur Y es que
por un lado el presidente de argentino
Alberto Fernández culpó a la Unión
Europea del retraso del acuerdo y en su
declaración unilateral Uruguay dice no
nosotros mercosur dejó de reunirse en
tres ocasiones con la Unión Europea por
falta de no tener un borrador a proponer
finalmente A quién se le puede atribuir
esta este retraso
yo no creo que haya que culpar a la
Unión Europea quizás han sí han habido
países que se han han opuesto
claramente insisto con Francia pero
también hay países que han impulsado
muchísimo como España Entonces no creo
que sea la Unión Europea el culpable de
de que esto no haya podido todavía
concretarse
hay muchas decisiones políticas influye
mucho la ideología
Pero
casi te diría que es uno una cosa más
una opinión subjetiva de parte de
nuestro presidente más que de la
realidad este concreta de los hechos
en lo que usted no dice interpreto que
para usted la responsabilidad de esta
lentitud está más del lado de mercosur
sí
perfecto quiero entonces ir con con
Nicolás Nicolás para ir cerrando china
Cuál es el temor que tiene de mercosur
frente a China y por qué la
imposibilidad de que Uruguay negocie un
tratado de libre comercio
bueno la imposibilidad de negociar un
acuerdo bilateral radica en lo que
conversábamos anteriormente los tratados
del mercosur este Están en contra van en
contra de la posibilidad de que cada uno
de sus miembros pueda bilateralmente
este negociar preferencias arancelarias
que perforen esa buscada Unión aduanera
entonces la vía bilateral se se cierra
por ese lado en cuanto a la búsqueda de
un acuerdo en conjunto aparecen diversas
dificultades este tanto para para los
países con con entramados industriales
este más extendidos como pueden ser
Argentina o Brasil china supone un
enorme desafío en materia de competencia
en bienes industriales mayor que la que
puede representar este un socio como la
Unión Europea por lo que allí tenemos un
fuerte desafío de economía política que
a su vez no es propio de de los países
de la región verdad este vemos que este
desafío de de la competencia china en
los mercados mundiales de manufacturas
ha afectado a incluso a las principales
potencias consolidadas en esta materia
sea europeas o norteamericanas y para
los países del mercosur con estos
entramados industriales esta presión
competitiva es incluso mayor a eso
tenemos que agregar un desafío de
naturaleza política que es que Paraguay
no mantiene relaciones diplomáticas con
la República popular china sino que
continúa manteniendo relaciones
diplomáticas con Taiwán por lo que
también tenemos este desafío diplomático
a la hora de pensar un acuerdo del
bloque con el gigante asiático en su
conjunto qué Creo yo que va a suceder
Bueno lo que estimo que que que los
países de Europa van a procurar este van
a explorar es la búsqueda de algunos
acuerdos más parciales o de acuerdos en
sectores específicos en los cuales haya
mayor espacio para la cooperación puede
ser un sector energético pueden ser
acuerdos este concretos de
financiamiento para el desarrollo de
algunos proyectos conjuntos pero veo que
el escenario de un acuerdo de libre
comercio de comercio preferencial más
abarcativo está muy en el lejano plazo
no no lo veo este que sea un un
escenario factible de corto mediano
plazo lejano plazo entonces puede estar
este tratado con china Delia Usted qué
opina al respecto es posible o no que
los países sea de manera individual o
como mercosur logran un tratado con los
chinos
bueno China ya es palabra mayor y es y
bien para muchos países es un gran
asociado un gran comparador también es
una gran amenaza
coincido con con Nicolás de que quizás
por ahora sea más posible más factible
acuerdos en determinadas áreas de
negocios sectores pero no del bloque yo
lo veo como más más si está si todavía
hay que destrabar muchos resortes con la
Unión Europea Me parece que con china va
a ser más complicado llegar a ese
acuerdo en bloque otro capítulo aparte
entonces que sin duda será muchísimo más
complicado Nicolás posa y Delia flores
Gracias por acompañarnos en el debate y
yo a ustedes nuestra audiencia les
cuento Que la producción de este
programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncel
y la de los invitados con Tania Herrera
también le agradezco al equipo técnico
que hizo posible este debate ustedes
sigan conectados con Franz 24
[Música]